It's tempting to think that a classic movie
was always made to be just the way it is.
But sometimes, there are scenes that were
planned and then scrapped, or even shot before
being deleted, that could have changed a movie
completely. For better or worse, here are
Screen Rant's10 Amazing Movie Scenes You
Will Never See.
The Avengers: Age of Ultron
Fans used to think that they would never see
Spider-Man share the screen with Marvel's
Avengers, or see Captain Marvel join the MCU
as early as they hoped. But according to Joss
Whedon, that was his original plan for the
second Avengers team-up film. After he delivered
a script that would include Captain Marvel
and Spider-Man in Cap's New Avengers lineup
at the end of the movie, the studio heads
told him to change it, since the plan had
changed. By the time the movie was hitting
theaters, Marvel had announced not only a
Captain Marvel movie, but that Spider-Man
would be coming to Civil War. Understandably,
Whedon made his disappointment well known.
The Dark Knight Rises
By the time the third Batman movie starts,
The Dent Act has been used to lock away hundreds
of criminals, all in the name of a lie about
Two-Face's real fate. But it's never actually
explained what the Dent Act did, or why repealing
it would be important. In a deleted scene,
it's revealed that the Act took away prisoner's
rights, including appeals. That would have
been explained when The Scarecrow was leading
Bane's new court, sentencing people to death
as punishment, completely turning the tables.
Jurassic Park
As brilliant as an amusement park full of
dinosaurs might be, it was a disaster waiting
to happen. By the movie's end, John Hammond
realizes his mistake - but he didn't in the
original script. In the first version, Hammond
refused to see the error of his ways, holding
on to plans for a park in Europe and Japan.
He even let the rest of the cast leave the
island in a helicopter after being attacked
by a T-rex, walking off into the jungle to
try to survive on his own. Which means sequels
would have been a problem.
Terminator 2: Judgement Day
The Terminator series is famous for its deleted
scenes and alternate endings, but one of the
coolest action sequences never even made it
into production. Judgement Day opens with
a brief look at the future war between humans
and Skynet, but James Cameron originally planned
to show an even longer, more expansive sequence.
It would have shown the humans defeating Skynet
for good, and even the re-programming of the
T-800 John Connor sends back to protect his
younger self. The scene was delivered in Terminator
Genisys, but fans would probably have preferred
to see Cameron's version.
Watchmen
Zack Snyder's movie adaptation of Alan Moore's
famous comic took a lot of heat for some changes
made, especially in the final act. But when
Terry Gilliam was attached to adapt the comic,
he had a different idea for the ending. Instead
of Ozymandias framing Dr. Manhattan for the
deaths of millions, he just convinced the
doctor to go back in time and stop his own
creation. He did, which led to the history
of our world, and sent the real heroes into
the pages of comic books. Pretty clever.
Star Wars: The Force Awakens
The latest Star Wars movie wastes no time
in getting to the action, but the movie was
originally going to open with a much darker
scene - one tying the events directly to the
original trilogy. After the opening text crawl,
audiences would have seen Luke's severed hand
floating through space, still holding his
lightsaber. The shot was eventually cut, but
with the lightsaber showing up in the movie
later, it raises some serious questions about
the actual storyline the writers had in mind.
Chronicle
Josh Trank's found footage movie was basically
a superhero origin story, minus the superhero.
In the finished cut, Matt takes out the villain,
and heads off into the mountains of Tibet.
But the original ending would have blown comic
book fans' minds. Matt would have evolved
to the next stage of his powers, showing uptwo
years lateras a full-blown superhero, saving
a Korean city from a massive flood with only
his mind. How's that for an origin story?
The Amazing Spider-Man 2
With Electro, Rhino, a new Green Goblin and
more, Andrew Garfield's second Spider-Man
movie was stuffed. But the movie was originally
planned to introduce Mary Jane Watson, Peter's
lifelong love, played by Shailene Woodley.
Their scenes were actually shot, but director
Marc Webb decided it was better to keep Gwen
Stacy in the spotlight, and introduce Mary
Jane in the sequel. The sequel never came,
which means fans will never know how Woodley's
MJ compared to those before or after.
The Dark Knight Rises
The villain of the movie didn’t amount to
the homerun performance of Heath Ledger's
Joker, but another deleted scene might have
helped him earn fans. The sequence would have
told an origin story of Bane, seeing the injuries
he sustained defending Talia al Ghul, the
first mask he wore, and even his training
in the League of Shadows. The training would
have called back to Bruce Wayne's in Batman
Begins, making their standoff in the last
chapter a perfect bookend to the trilogy as
a whole. Why it wasn't included is something
Christopher Nolan will have to explain (but
probably won't).
Back to the Future
Forget scenes, how about an entire movie you'll
never get to see? When the first photos of
Eric Stoltz on the set of Back to the Future
started to appear, the full story came out
not long after. Stoltz had landed the part
of Marty McFly, but the studio soon realized
he wasn't the right fit. Rather than scrapping
the production, it continued on, filming the
other actors knowing full well Stoltz's sides
would need to be reshot. The evidence suggests
there's a cut of the movie, or most of it,
starring Stoltz that fans won't ever get to
see.
Those are the wildest, coolest, or weirdest
scenes that movie fans almost got to see,
but probably never will. Which ones did we
miss? Let us know the planned-but-cancelled
movie scenes you'd kill to see, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!